not that we needed more evidence to
question the mental stability of the
president but he spent his weekend
obviously at one of his golf resorts
this time the one in New Jersey spent
his weekend tweeting about various
conspiracies and of course about
Hillary's emails he's been president for
a year and a half and he's still
tweeting about Hillary's emails and it's
very quickly becoming like having
conspiracy theorists Alex Jones as
president of the United States Donald
Trump tweeting rife with the bizarre
grammar and capitalization that we've
become accustomed to over the weekend
quote the rigged witch-hunt originally
headed by FBI loverboy Peter S for one
year and now thirteen angry Democrats
should look into the missing DNC server
crooked Hillary's illegally deleted
emails the Pakistani fraudster uranium
one Podesta and so much more
it's a Democrat con job I don't know
where to start okay so let this is like
under fifty words I think I counted it's
like forty seven words here's what he
has squeezed into this small number of
words which is actually a sort of
literary achievement to squeeze this
much nonsense into only forty seven
words he calls the Russia investigation
of witch-hunt no evidence of that that's
a popular one of for Trump the Peter
asks that he refers to his Peters struck
this is the guy who was an FBI agent
didn't head the investigation he was one
of many people that were involved and
once his anti-trump text messages came
to light he was removed from the
investigation in fact the handling of
the Peter Strock situation was done 100%
correctly and has not yet not indicative
of any wrongdoing by the FBI Trump then
talks about thirteen angry Democrats
that's Trump claiming that thirteen
Democrats at the FBI run the entire
investigation which is court of course
not true and as you probably know Robert
Muller the guy in charge he's a lifelong
Republican Trump references a missing
DNC server there are missing records of
all kinds on both Democratic and
Republican sides not really a unique
thing we have a problem in our governor
with records going missing talks about
Hillary's emails Hillary lost almost two
years ago I don't know why he's still
talking about Hillary's emails he even
said that even though his priority was
going to be to lock her up that it's not
actually going to be so why he's talking
about it I don't know then he mentions
this Pakistani fraudster now that you
may not have heard about that refers to
an individual whose last name is a Wan
who's connected to a government IT
situation a Wan was a former IT aide for
Debbie wasserman-schultz and he made
unauthorized access to the servers of
the House of Representatives but again
it has nothing to do with the Trump
Russia investigation whatsoever he
brings up uranium one that's of course
the completely debunked conspiracy
theory that there's different versions
of it but one is Hillary illegally gave
all of our uranium to Russia and there's
actually even crazier versions of that
one even Shepard Smith on Fox News
debunked it and then he just says
Podesta that's not really anything
that's just referring to John John
Podesta is a person he refers to John
Podesta but that's not really anything a
single 47 word tweet with eight
distortions or straight-up conspiracy
theories
well David the president is busy he
works something like 20 hours a day he
barely sleeps yes you know ending the
Korean War on Monday and resuscitating
the coal industry on Tuesday he doesn't
have time to fact-check he doesn't have
time to spellcheck you're expecting too
much from him this is what happens when
you have an Alex Jones presidency or
some guy who watches Fox News in the
Oval Office and it's not how a stable
genius behaves and if you're Justin
Trudeau or a Manuel McCrone or Angela
Merkel Angela Merkel what do you think
when you see this stuff and actually we
know what they think and we know that
Trump doesn't care what they think
because he's alienated them completely
what does Putin think when he sees this
stuff he thinks everything's going
exactly to plan and is very very pleased
we have yet another victim of the Trump
tax cuts and they are the potential
employees of BMW who were not going to
be hired who are not going to get a job
because BMW is choosing to expand in
China in
stead of the United States so for now
BMW is introducing production in the US
although Trump has sort of talked about
getting German cars off American roads
which was really weird because a lot of
those companies employ many American
workers but BMW is choosing to expand
their manufacturing in China instead of
the United States and starting next year
BMW is going to produce more than half a
million cars in China last year about a
third of the cars sold in China were
actually imported from other countries
including SUVs made in the United States
and of course as you probably know by
now Trump put a 25% additional tariff on
thirty four billion dollars in Chinese
imports this includes cars so China has
also retaliated when it comes to that
and BMW smartly obviously like I'm not
cheering it but I understand why they're
doing it they say well we're gonna avoid
the tariffs by making the cars that we
sell in China in China to begin with and
these are jobs that could have gone to
American workers Trump said he wanted to
help American workers but these are jobs
that are going to go to the Chinese
instead and yesterday I've been thinking
about what's the endgame here right how
can we get off of this escalating trade
war and contrary to what Trump has said
trade wars aren't always good and
they're not always easy to win but if
they're going to end both sides need to
know what they need to have happen in
order to end them there's no indication
Trump knows what he would need he's
vaguely talked about China's unfair to
us on trade and they steal our
intellectual property okay well how do
you make that a policy if China just
says we won't steal intellectual
property anymore is that enough will
that get Trump to say we're ready to end
this and unfortunately there are lots of
people who are emailing me saying if
only X happened we could just undo these
tariffs and go back to where we were I
hate to break it to you but nearly a
dozen economic experts are saying that
once you have tariffs like these in
place it takes a while to remove them
and very often even before negotiations
happen around the
specifically you'll see countries see if
they can maybe come to agreements on
other things sort of like proxy
negotiations there's thought they're
gonna start to feel out can we cooperate
on other geopolitical issues if and when
it feels like progress has been made
then you would look at the idea of
scaling down the tariff so Trump very
quickly irrationally haphazardly started
the tariffs didn't seem like he knew
much about trade or what the impacts
would be and now we're going to be stuck
with this for a long time because these
off ramps can take a long time to
actually put in place and step one is
the Trump administration needs to be
clear about what they want it's not even
clear that they know it right now Trump
says treat us fairly on trade well what
does that look like Trump says China
needs to stop stealing intellectual
property well what does that look like
when it comes to an agreement and would
he just take the Chinese president's
word on that they don't know because
they're clueless and this was done
haphazardly good luck getting out of
this any time soon you know it by now
when I say there was a moment of truth
or of clarity or of honesty on Fox News
it's almost always Shepard Smith except
when it isn't Fox News anchor
commentator I don't even know really
what her role is at this point Dagan
McDowell
she said what we all know is true which
is that if President Obama pulled the
tariffs that Trump is now putting in
place the right would be calling for
Obama's head if you thought that the
right went nuts when Trump when Obama
rather wore a tan suit just imagine what
the right would have done if Obama had
placed tariffs on our key allies and
suppliers of products and dagen mcdowell
says something which is actually very
uncontroversial it's obviously true it's
just kind of out of place on Fox News
you're right the market is really
tolerating this the market has not
collapsed and certainly the economy in
the second quarter is growing at a great
clip so maybe we can handle this but
this strategy that we talked about has
not been it laid out clearly and we've
heard about
retaliation the European Europe has
talked about coming back with tariffs on
300 billion dollars in goods which is
one-fifth of all of our exports every
year so there is a grave concern and
I'll point this out if President Obama
had pulled what we've seen in the last
six months we would be shouting to the
high heavens blowing the roof off this
bill would be absolutely ways faster
when everybody talks at the same time
but digging McDowell was absolutely
right if Obama did this the right would
be saying this is protectionist nanny
government Indonesian Kenyan Muslim
foreign-born Barack Hussein Obama
screwing us again but Obama wasn't
ignorant enough or depraved enough or
delusional enough to try to start a
trade war with half the world so yes
right-wing media would have lost their
minds if Obama did this put Obama never
would have thought of even proposing
something like this yeah and really you
can make this hypocrisy point on just
about every political issue I think
she's making it here though because
there are many Republicans there out
there who are in support of free trade
who are also against these tariffs is
safer you know the Koch brothers are too
and probably the people who run Fox News
so it is very safe I mentioned soybean
farmers yesterday and NPR had an
interesting piece about soybean farmers
who by and large in the Midwest support
Donald Trump and they're getting very
nervous about these tariffs but they
mostly still support Donald Trump and
these people are sticking with Trump
even as he destroys their industries and
I want to show you the level of
cognitive dissonance that's going on
there was an article in Kansas City calm
they went to Poplar Bluff Missouri
ravaged by these tariffs almost
immediately and here are quotes just
from people in the community okay it
would be a detriment to our community
said Carol McGee but when you look at
the bigger picture blaming him solely
meaning Trump is not necessarily
accurate well he chose to do this entire
tariff proposal who else are you gonna
blame I guess whoever gave him the idea
probably wasn't his idea
also from this Kansas
calm article he's the only one who
hasn't lied about what he was going to
do in office insists Eric Turner a chef
so although the tariffs he's going to
drive although through the tariffs quote
he's going to drive up the cost of
everything people are still going to
stand behind him that's exactly right
they are going through and it's horrible
also from the article Faust son Sean
said if his friends who work there do
lose their jobs quote I don't think it
will turn them against the president
even if on the surface it's going to
look bad I agree they're not gonna turn
against the guy another quote from the
article there is going to be some
short-term pain says nurse anesthetist
Don Faust and I don't like for anyone to
have pain in their lives but we've had
unfair trade directed against the US for
years and we've just taken it so some of
these things are gonna have to happen
before some of these economic issues get
hashed out these people don't know
anything about trade Trump is convinced
them with his vague proclamations about
being treated unfairly that he knows the
solutions to the trade problem guy
doesn't even actually understand the
problem and people who know nothing
about economics are now blindly saying
Trump's identified the problems could be
a little rough in the meantime but
ultimately we're going to get the
solutions the solutions are going to
come when Trump's replacement
comes up with the solutions they're not
going to come under Trump and this is
why you have to vote in November because
these people are telling you doesn't
matter how bad it gets doesn't matter
how bad it gets for me or my town or my
state there's some bigger picture
strategy that Trump has here and they're
going to continue supporting him so Rudy
Giuliani appeared on ABC's program this
week with George Stephanopoulos and he
seemed to I guess inadvertently unless
it's part of some campaign to
deliberately so confusion which it very
well may be Giuliani
appeared to admit that Donald Trump
obstructed justice by asking James Comey
then FBI director to give indicted
National Security Advisor Michael Flynn
a break in the Russia probe and Rudy
Giuliani insists out of one side of his
mouth that there's just nothing to see
here
but then he admits that well yeah the
President did say specific
things to james comey about how to
handle the Michael Flynn situation which
would be a way of in a literal sense
getting in the way
obstructing interfering the natural
course of justice being carried out by
an investigation the clip is stunning it
is only 28 seconds but it contains so
much wackiness that i want you to pay
really close attention to these 28
seconds I mean the reality is Comey
in some ways ends up being a good
witness for us unless you assume they're
trying to get him into a perjury trap by
he tells his version somebody else has a
different version how is he a good
witness for the president if he's saying
that the president was asking directing
him and his words to let the Michael son
investigation go he didn't direct him to
do that what he said to him was can you
can you give Comey says he took it as
directly that's okay I'm taking it that
way I meant by that time you have been
fired and you said a lot of other things
some of which has turned out to be
untrue this is just completely untrue I
mean he's completely revising the
timeline into one that if my current
understanding of time is moving forward
and we can't like travel back in time or
change the past currently like that's my
understanding and maybe in the future
these are things we'll be able to do I
don't think Giuliani is referring to
sort of like a break in the space-time
continuum here this is not the way it
happened Rudy Giuliani who is Trump's
own lawyer is admitting that during the
time when Jeff bi director James Comey
was FBI director he was told by the
President to look at giving a break to
National Security Advisor
Michael Flynn that is direction when it
comes to a specific invest investigate
and it is obstruction of justice and I
know I know
unless Trump is impeached it won't make
a difference you likely can't indict a
sitting president but that doesn't
change whether it's obstruction and it
is and the executive branch directing
the FBI to handle a particular
investigation in a particular way
including being lacks right giving Flynn
a break that is asking for before there
is a an actual indictment before there
is a trial before there is a sentencing
it's saying just give them a break on
the entire thing which which of course
at that phase in the investigation means
maybe let the entire thing go is George
Stefon
points out now remember this also
contradicts that Trump said when asked
this exact same thing last year that he
never said anything like it to James
Comey so Giuliani Trump's personal
lawyer is making this comment from Trump
last year appeared to be shocker untrue
Thank You mr. president in the light of
a very busy news week a lot of people
would like to get to the bottom of a
couple of things give you a chance to go
on record here did you at any time
urge former FBI director James Comey in
any way shape or form to close or to
back down the investigation into Michael
Flynn and also as you know next question
well his whole lawyer Rudy Giuliani is
now saying the opposite and at first
Rudy Giuliani said he was contradicting
Trump remember when he was first hired
by Trump and then he said all sorts of
things that were the opposite of what
Trump said he said well I was just hired
and I'm kind of trying to figure things
out later he was asked about it and he
said well those were just rumors right
rumors created by him apparently he
wrote them off as just rumors what's the
excuse now and I'm not asking
rhetorically I genuinely am wondering
how is it that Rudy Giuliani continues
to directly contradict Trump and is it a
strategy merely to create confusion yeah
why do they keep putting him on the
sunday talk shows I know he had a few
week hiatus
yes you're really gonna put this guy
back he keeps putting his foot in his
mouth and you would have imagined that
was the hiatus during which he was
informing himself about the relevant
facts related to all of this stuff but
apparently not I think in the end
pardons are gonna be flying soon and
none of this stuff is gonna matter and
we like to think in general that people
know what they're doing but we are aware
of these ideas that 80% of people are
incompetent at what they do
we still imagine that okay even if 80%
of lawyers are sometimes incompetent the
president's lawyers those would be the
best people and maybe that's not the
case unless of course this is and this
is a counter-argument people emailed me
about they said something along the
lines of Rudy Giuliani is contradicting
Trump to obfuscate and confuse so that
no one really knows what's true and
becomes distrustful of everything that
they hear and just kind of give up on
figuring out what's going on which is
less like 1984 by
well but more like brave new world by
Aldous Huxley that is more reminiscent
of what was laid out by Aldous Huxley
which is who even really knows what's
true I'll just figure out something else
to think about yeah you were talking
about the confusion over when you know
if time is moving forward or backward or
what's going on with that maybe that's
the 40 chests that they're talking about
always yes it's 7 dimensional underwater
chess played only when it's completely
dark out between the hours of 2 a.m. and
4 a.m. and somehow they're playing
they're playing the game masterfully or
something like that if an investigation
were about to end would the guy running
the investigation hire even more
prosecutors you tell me Donald Trump has
been telling us for a long time now that
we're almost at the end of this thing
the Moller investigation is just about
to end we heard last year that it would
be over by Thanksgiving 2017 when it
didn't end we were told it would be over
by New Year's Day January 1 2018
that didn't happen throughout early 2018
and even over the last month or so we've
been told time and time again that it's
it's almost over we're really almost at
the end here and we learned over the
weekend that special counsel Robert
Muller has hired even more prosecutors
to work the investigation prosecutors as
the name implies prosecute you hire them
if you want them to partake in
prosecution and prosecution related
activities and the report is that Robert
Muller is going to be expanding that
team and potentially even stepping away
from some of the casework
I've said it before and I'm going to
remind you if the investigation ended
today the prosecution of the cases we
already have could take years if we have
another six to 12 months of
investigation and further indictments we
are looking at this stretching into
Donald Trump's second term for sure or
potentially even into well depending on
whether Trump wins or loses the next
president's first term so far we have 20
indictments and five guilty pleas at the
end of the day I don't pretend to know
what will happen I get emails from
people Pat who say David why are you so
sure that XYZ is going to go down or
that trumps inner circle is gonna end up
in prison I've never said anything like
that I don't know what's ultimately
going to happen what I do know is that
number one there's no evidence or
indication that this investigation is
almost over that's number one number two
we know that Watergate took years that
means that this may take years if this
is bigger than Watergate
it could take significantly longer than
Watergate and this gets us right back to
don't beat me up Pat but I've got to
mention it this gets us right back to
voting in 2018 and 2020 I was thinking
over the weekend why might someone want
to vote in November well as I mentioned
earlier don't hurt me
I know I mentioned this midterm turnout
is often low that means your vote if you
choose to vote matters more House and
Senate control is key to stopping the
Trump agenda taking over the House and
Senate in 2018 better positions you to
win in 2020 but related to the Muller
investigation Muller can say whatever he
wants he can issue whatever findings he
wants to issue Republicans are not going
to act on Mulder's findings Muller has
been smeared and discredited and while
it's bogus it works with the right it
works with Republicans and that is going
to provide cover for Republicans when
Moeller finally tells us whatever it is
that he found Republicans will say these
are political reports we can't act on
what Muller found because Muller is
compromised which is why Democrats must
take over the House and Senate so that
they will act on whatever Muller's
findings are yeah and it's also becoming
increasingly clear that a sitting
president cannot be indicted
so if Trump is going to face any
criminal repercussions for what he may
have done it would have to come through
impeachment after yeah yeah and that's
not gonna happen if Democrats don't have
control of the House or Senate no
question about it no question about it
so whatever you care about if it's
seeing consequences to the Moller
investigation or seeing the tariffs that
are destroying farmers who by the way
are mostly still supporting Trump even
though Trump is hurting them it's
stunning cognitive dissonance that's
going on whatever is important to you it
all leads back to voting in
November what what's the date I should
so I would be able to say November 6th
is it the 6th don't hold me to that yeah
I don't know what they in the first week
of November of 2018 quick break we will
be back after this discuss this or any
stories of interest from today's show on
the David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD i.t ok I told you last week that the
retirement of Supreme Court Justice
Anthony Kennedy stunk
everything about it stunk it didn't
sound right we knew about the
connections between Donald Trump and
Anthony Kennedy's son at Deutsche Bank
Justin Kennedy the timing was odd it was
something that reportedly came as a sort
of surprise to the other justices the
other justices are usually sort of
notified in advance when a Supreme Court
justice plans to retired and now not
only do we have news that a deal was
made for Kennedy's retirement the White
House isn't even denying it and this is
quickly becoming one of the biggest
stories of cronyism and corruption and
strong-arming involving the Trump
administration and the Supreme Court and
that says a lot because we've seen a lot
of cronyism and corruption and
strong-arming that this administration
has been involved that here is what we
know we've learned that the Trump
administration was negotiating the
retirement of Justice Anthony Kennedy
with Anthony Kennedy and they ultimately
assured Kennedy in advance that if he
retired they would replace him with
Brett Kavanaugh whose nomination we
learned about on Monday night and as the
story goes during the negotiations but
took place took place in 2017 Anthony
Kennedy gave Trump a list of people who
he would be ok with as a replacement
and this reportedly goes all the way
back to late 2017 I said yesterday that
Cavanaugh wasn't on the original list
remember originally Trump said I'm gonna
pick justices from this list and it was
like a Heritage Foundation or some
right-wing think tank list Cavanaugh
wasn't on that list originally but he
was added to the list in November with
four other names what we've now learned
according to the reporting that that has
surfaced in the last 24 hours
is that back in November when Brett
Cavanaugh was added to the list
with four other names it had already
been negotiated that Cavanaugh would be
the replacement to Anthony Kennedy but
that it would be too suspicious if you
only say remember that list from two
years ago or from a year ago I'm gonna
just add one name to that list don't
worry about it has nothing to do with
anything we're involved in that would be
too suspicious so four additional names
were added as deliberate red herrings to
cover up that Cavanaugh was already the
guy who was being negotiated to replace
Justice Anthony Kennedy at that time we
are seeing a total subjugation of checks
and balances were seeing the
circumvention of the independence of
branches of government and what's the
wackiest of all is that the White House
isn't denying it yesterday deputy press
secretary Raj Shah who is only surpassed
in his vile and depraved nature by his
number one in command Sara Huckabee
Sanders the actual press secretary Raj
Shah said yesterday some assurances may
have been made and not denying anything
about this story take a look in the
selection process did President Trump
speak to outgoing Justice Anthony
Kennedy at all about Judge Cavanaugh
prior to the nomination so the President
did speak with Justice Kennedy yesterday
to inform him of his choice prior to
that John yeah let me answer and he met
with Justice Kennedy at the White House
on the Wednesday of the week before last
when Justice Kennedy made his
announcement so the president has talked
to Justice Kennedy but this was the
president's choice understand that Judge
Cavanaugh was on his publicly disclosed
list as far back as last November right
he was on the list since last November
because he was added along with four
other names as political cover and it
had already been negotiated this
continues with Raja the Justice Kennedy
expressed his support for judge
Cavanaugh prior to the nomination last
week
well I'll allow Justice Kennedy to speak
for himself obvious
judge Cavanaugh did clerk for him in the
Supreme Court so did a few others that's
what we call a yes in political press
secretary speak and we have yet another
instance of a non-denial here there are
reports this morning that as far back as
months ago that Brett Kavanaugh was used
Justice Kennedy basically made clear
that he would like to see judge
Kavanaugh as his replacement did anyone
inside the White House are connected to
the White House speak to Anthony Kennedy
about judge Cavanaugh dating back months
well again I'm not gonna read out
private conversations that Justice
Kennedy had with either members of the
White House or the president ding that's
another yes this went on for six minutes
no denials because it's all true it's
all true Justice Anthony Kennedy has
given control of a seat has has had
control of a seat not only for his time
on the court but for whatever number of
years Brett Kavanaugh ends up being on
the court and soon the story will change
too it's not illegal anyway so who cares
and of course it doesn't matter even if
it were illegal the Democrats deserved
it because of either Hillary's emails or
uranium 1 or some such nonsense that
come up with Supreme Court justices are
supposed to have more integrity than
this and there's a lot here that stinks
be it that Kavanagh clerked for Kennedy
or you know the very specifics of this
deal like the fact that Cavanaugh's son
I had some shady business dealings with
Donald Trump at one point any son if
he's not having us on we're not breaking
any news here I just to 2k names there
step back for a second and ask yourself
what if Obama had done this what if it
had been revealed that Obama was given a
name a list of names of replacements to
pick from by the retiring justice and he
did it six months prior to the
retirement or eight months prior to the
retirement and that the name was added
surreptitiously with four other
deliberate red herrings to a list to
cover the fact that the replacement had
already been selected forget about that
what if Obama had pre announced he'd be
picking from a list at all when the list
came from a think tank it would be a
very very different situation and
right-wing media would be absolutely
losing their minds and what this gets us
to you know where it gets us too
vote this November send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show Donald
Trump is not going to like this the New
Mexican president-elect is going to be
canceling an order of eight military
helicopters from the United States
planned to cost one point thirty six
billion dollars and the explanation is
merely cost-cutting measures this is
something that the New Mexican
president-elect ran on but more than
likely this is going to be seen by
Donald Trump as just yet another attack
from our neighbors to the south some of
whom I assume are good people and we
need to start being treated fairly and
we're going to have to give them some
good old-fashioned trade wars and these
helicopters were going to be
manufactured by Lockheed Martin Lockheed
Martin is one of the main players in the
military industrial complex and although
this really is not as far as we know
meant as a protest of the Trump regime
de-facto it is another one of these
so-called attacks on the United States
the way that the Trump Ian Wright sees
things and it genuinely does not seem
like it is because of Donald Trump it
doesn't seem to even relate to US Mexico
relations it's just what the guy
promised to do but if you look online
the right-wingers are going crazy
they're demanding punishment of Mexico
and I'm reminded of that phrase if all
you have is a hammer everything looks
like a nail right if you're committed to
the narrative that everybody is treating
the United States unfairly and everybody
who does so or is perceived to be
treating the United States unfairly
needs to be punished than every decision
that's made by another country looks to
you like an attack on the United States
now that being said if you start
thinking about what might happen more
broadly if Donald Trump continues to
alienate other countries the way that
he's been doing the military-industrial
complex is going to suffer greatly right
it's not going to be just whiskey and
motorcycle manufacturers and aside from
what the helicopters coming from the
United States to Mexico we're going to
cost
is the right decision from Mexico right
like aside from military industrial
complex stuff aside from us-mexico
relations stuff there's massive poverty
in Mexico the economy has improved there
and we do have now a net outflow to
Mexico because the economy has improved
but there are still major economic
problems in Mexico spending 1.36 billion
on American helicopters to protect elite
politicians and do whatever else they
were going to do with them it's not the
best look so I think that completely
aside from whether you want to support
or not an American helicopter company or
a French helicopter company or whatever
this is a good decision
yeah and military spending through
defense contractors is a bottomless pit
and we yes falling down that pit for a
long time now you think though do you
think that the military-industrial
complex at some point which has such
clout in the United States will start
speaking out against Trump's foreign
policy once it starts to hurt them
because a lot of contractor dollars come
from foreign policy and they come from
relationships with other countries
if Trump starts alienating other
countries such that they say well then
we'll get our helicopter somewhere else
or we'll get our bombs somewhere else
I'm not up to speed on everybody who
manufactures this stuff but there are
places other than the US you might see
an industry that has a natural alignment
with the Republican Party the
military-industrial complex saying we
are against what Donald Trump is doing
well maybe it would be playing with fire
though because what Trump and the
Republicans have increased military
spending so significantly but we will
see that pushback from the right on
trade like the Koch brothers are against
these tariffs for example yeah and that
our the Koch brothers still considered
libertarian kind of right I mean I just
won't read white people
what is libertarian even at this point
but yet they they I guess under the idea
that they are yes they are more in the
total free trade side of the American
right than some of these other elements
the new president in Mexico the
president-elect is realizing that these
are corrupt crony capitalist deals he
campaigned on cutting this stuff and
he's doing it and it's kind of like
refreshingly simple and straightforward
well you know what I think it is one
point three six billion dollars that's a
lot of money he's saving up to pay for
the cost of the US Mexican border wall
oh yeah that's what it is he's very
clever I like that
I'm very interested in getting down in
Mexico soon my travel to Mexico has
mostly been you know going to these
beach areas where you just hang out and
it is Mexico and you get to see some
stuff I've been to Chichen Itza I've
been to some other historical sites sort
of in the in the Yucatan area I love the
Mexican people but it hasn't been like
the authentic Mexican experience overall
there are now non-stop daily flights
from Boston direct to Mexico City there
you go and I would be very interested in
visiting Mexico City although we know
that I don't do great with the elevation
and I think Mexico City is at like
10,000 feet how do I believe there it's
the biggest city in this side of the
world billions of people huge yeah
absolutely huge huge cities so yeah I'm
interested in visiting as soon as
possible and some friends of mine have
recently been and they said they just
had a fantastic time we're gonna start
today with a media story I'm gonna
present to you today the epitome of
right-wing media dishonesty and
distortion and it's gonna be
specifically talking about the economy
and employment numbers so last week as
often happens in the first few days of a
new month we get the jobs numbers from
the previous month
we got them late last week from June
there were totally unremarkable job
numbers for June more or less a
continuation of similar numbers that we
saw what we saw under President Obama
213 thousand jobs were added during the
Obama administration 214 thousand jobs
per month were added that was during
Obama's second term the unemployment
rate went up slightly to 4% very small
change I've been telling you for years
and years how the unemployment rate is
calculated it's been calculated the same
way for a very long time very often when
you have low unemployment numbers under
a democratic president you will see
Republicans say when people stop looking
for work they're no longer count that is
unemployed so the number doesn't mean
anything and then all of a sudden when a
Republican has low unemployment numbers
Republicans seem to completely forget
that they were critical of how that
number is formulated when it was Barack
Obama or a Democrat what we do often see
Republicans talk about when there is a
Democrat in the White House is the
number of people who were not working
sometimes this is used interchangeably
with the labor force participation
right and I've been telling you for a
year after year after year that the raw
number of people that are working or the
raw number of people that are not
working the labor force participation
rate they are very often misleading
sometimes useless and almost 100 percent
at a time those numbers are used for
political gain by whoever is looking to
distort the reality of the economy it
communicates almost nothing about to the
about the economy to say X number of
people are working and the headline that
Drudge Report right-wing propagandists
rudra poor Tran when the June numbers
came out red record 155 million employed
this is presumably the number of people
with jobs in the United States I am also
going to show you the headline from the
same website Drudge Report on March 8th
of 2013 when Barack Obama was president
the headline read eighty-nine point
three million not working the number of
people not who are unemployed but people
who aren't in the labor force right so
when Drudge said eighty nine million not
working that included retired people
that included full-time college students
it included stay-at-home parents who
don't need to work because they are
well-off financially and what you need
to understand to realize how you are
being manipulated or there are attempts
to manipulate you with these numbers
remember that the population of the
United States has been going up forever
at many times in American history there
have been record numbers of people
working at the same time that you had
record numbers of people not working you
can display either number to make a
political point and case in point as I
told you a month ago maybe it was two
months ago there are also a record
number of people not working right now
just as right now we have if you believe
the numbers from Drudge Report more
people than ever working because there
are more people in the United
it states than ever before the numbers
mean nothing and following Drudge Report
right-wing media just jumped all over
this thing as if it was some miracle and
I hate to break it to them but sometimes
record numbers of people working isn't a
positive thing and I'll explain the
percentage not the number the percentage
of people over 85 years of age 85 or
older working today is very high
back in 2006 before the the recession
2.6 percent of those 85 or older were
working 2.6 percent today you have
almost twice as many people over age 85
working they're part of the victorious
great economy of record numbers of
people working right well hold on let's
just think about it for a second some
people who are over age 85 are working
because they want to some people over
age 85 are working because 85 year olds
are slightly healthier today than they
were in 2006 on average although there
hasn't actually been that big of a
change but overall when you read that
part of the record number of people
working is a higher than ever rate of 85
plus year-olds you have to think about
it and realize wait a second there's
more eighty five year olds than ever
working because they have to because
wages are stagnant because cost of
living goes up as wages are stagnant and
Pat this is how the right-wing media
spins these bogus narratives they put up
a number record 155 million working it
means nothing and it becomes the talking
point for the month of July yeah I
remember shortly after the Trump
administration began Sean Spicer was
saying that the president didn't believe
the strong jobs numbers under Obama
right but now the Trump is president he
obviously does believe them but I mean
that that was at least delivered
somewhat tongue-in-cheek I guess it's a
lot of hypocrisy when he said that it
wasn't clear whether it was like a 90
percent joke or a 50 percent joke but
there was like some understanding of the
political nature of the numbers it was
the Drudge Report they're trying to
deceive you and sightings actually
succeeded with many of us they do and
unfortunately the audience that it is
being delivered to is eating it up like
it is being just
all fed to them and it's it's any small
amount of critical analysis applied to
that tells you that it is merely spoon
feeding nonsense to a hungry audience
that's all it is sometimes on the David
Pakman show we talk about ignorance on
major life-altering issues like
ignorance on climate change
ignorance on basic economics or on net
neutrality and sometimes we talk about
ignorant on the littler things and this
is sort of an in-between Donald Trump
seems to think that DNA tests like the
ones you get from ancestry.com or
23andme cost $2 and will tell you where
you were born and when I first heard
about this my initial reaction was that
this can't possibly be true and then I
remembered well Trump did confuse health
insurance and life insurance he wasn't
sure why it wasn't a good idea to nuke
Europe he had this wacky rally in
Montana totally lost his mind at it and
he seemed to say that when you do a DNA
test which he thinks you buy for 2 bucks
off of I guess a TV infomercial I don't
know I don't know what channels he's
watching it will tell you the country
you were born and this is funny for a
number of reasons but the number one
reason is do that many people not know
where they were born
check out this cringe-worthy video of
Donald Trump let's say I'm debating
Pocahontas right I promise you I'll do
this I will take you know those little
kits they sell on television for two
dollars learn your heritage guy says I
was born in Scotland it turns out he was
born in Puerto Rico and that's ok good
you know ok says I was born in Germany
well he wasn't born in Germany he was
born someplace else I'm gonna get one of
those little kids how great is this most
people ask their mom or dad where they
were born not everyone right like there
are unique situations where someone
might not know where they were born
different situations we can imagine most
people know not only does the DNA does
not tell you where you were born
most people know where they were born
yeah I think he's confusing Elizabeth
Warren with Barack Obama North to find
out where Obama was born which he of
course says Kenya yes
fortunately the DNA test won't tell you
that and I mean okay on the $2 thing
Trump supposedly a billionaire so maybe
two dollars and two hundred dollars is
really no difference the same thing to
him but DNA tests tell you where you
were born and if your question is how
does this guy get away with this stuff I
figured it out he's slightly smarter
than his supporters so when he makes
these statements they just don't
register as that stupid because he's
just he only has to be the tiniest bit
more informed than his supporters and
the context in case you couldn't tell he
mentioned the word Pocahontas the
context is his continuing obsession with
Senator Elizabeth Warren's partial
Native American heritage the issue won't
die with Trump it's like Hillary's
emails or Hillary's uranium one
conspiracy or Hillary's three to five
million illegal votes the trend is it
has to a lot to do with Hillary
it just won't die and he seems fixated
on this thing and people might have
forgotten Pat but I actually did an
ancestry.com DNA test and a 23andme
dot-com DNA test and we've had blamed
Bettinger whose F DNA expert on the
program if you missed that episode he
revealed to the audience in incredibly
dramatic fashion that he has never seen
someone with a higher percentage of
Ashkenazi Jewish DNA than my DNA which
was a finding that was both interesting
to normal people and triggering for the
anti-semitic hatreds yeah I took that
ancestry DNA test too and it said that I
was less than 1% Ashkenazi Jewish which
I thought was pretty interesting yeah
although he told us less than 1% is
often just statistical noise and it
basically is like zero so I'm not Indian
or american either it no I don't think
so okay I think you got what did yours
come out it was like British and
Lebanese British Irish Lebanese Italian
Greek Polish Russian a little of
everything was there anything that was
surprising about what was you know is
Italian in Greek you didn't know now I
got to eat a bunch of pasta and embrace
my heritage right yes no you should do
the most stereotypical things that would
be colloquially associated without with
all of those Heritage's anyway I think
that I got screwed with my test because
it didn't tell me where I was born
that's something I would I would have
liked to know because I only think I
know the end